bonjour jean claude bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions auparavant le
facebook était le porte drapeau de
l'innovation aux états unis mais
maintenant le réseau social est de plus
en plus critiqué aux etats-unis pour ses
positions dominantes pourquoi comment
expliquer cette volte-face
alors c'est à la fois un double axe
juridique tout d'abord les poursuites
pour lutte anti concurrentielles ne sont
pas nouvelles aux états unis elle repose
sur un texte extrêmement important aux
états unis clayton et sherman act qui
date du début des ateliers et le 1914
précisément et donc qui visait à faire
sauter les grands conglomérats
industriels alors aujourd'hui il ya
peut-être moins de grands conglomérats
industriels mais il y a les grands
groupes de communication les grands
groupes de médias sociaux
et c'est vrai que fait facebook à la
fois à qui il y a deux ans en 2012
précisément et après deux ans et en 2012
à qui est instagram acquis watsa et donc
les autorités américains considèrent que
le groupe
le groupe facebook comprenant facebook
instagram watsa et peut-être demain
le costaud morts sont trop importants et
nuise à la concurrence nuisent à la
libre concurrence entre en tout et en
cause l'accusation qui est porté c'est
qu'elle le groupe abuseraient de sa
position dominante sur le marché
américain
j'ajoute que la particularité de cette
affaire tient au fait que aussi bien
côté républicain que côté démocrate
il y à des critiques à l'encontre du
groupe du groupe facebook on entendu ken
buck le upper républicain du colorado on
a entendu aussi cicillini un démocrate
de new york et surtout ses mises aussi
dans la boucle
la paire net général du de new york
l'équivalent du ministre de la justice
de new york
letitia james qui considère que depuis
plus de dix ans se sont un peu ces mots
qui considère que depuis peu plus depuis
10 ans de facebook aurait abusé de sa
position dominante en achetant ses
rivaux de manière à limiter la
concurrence
ans en tout cas à user de son pouvoir de
domination sur le marché
limiter la concurrence à la défaveur des
consommateurs donc cette procédure est
ce qu elle a des chances d'aboutir
vous savez il ya encore trop tôt pour
pouvoir le dire parce que là on est sûr
de très très gros dossier comment est-ce
que les chaussons sont appréciés le fait
d'être dominant ou d'être en situation
de monopole n'est pas en soi une
infraction au regard de la loi américain
ni même d'ailleurs
en gros ce qui est interdit c'est de
l'abus de cette position donc il y a
dans ce type de dossier il y à une
analyse extrêmement fine sur le plan
économique on va regarder sur le plan
commercial
est ce que un acteur en particulier et
la houle de mur facebook en conscience
de sa position dominante à user de cette
position dominante dans sa pratique
commerciale par exemple en augmentant
les prix de manière à musique par
exemple en ayant des comportements
commerciaux qui empêcherait de nouveaux
entrants voilà c'est ce que c'est ce que
regarde en général les investigateurs
vous savez on est sûr c'est vraiment du
droit économique sur ce type de dossier
on est à la fois sur une analyse
économique et julie économiques et
commerciales et on regarde endroit est
ce qu'il y à une infraction à la loi
donc il est encore trop tôt pour dire
mais j'imagine que si le la federal
trade commission qui est l'équivalent de
la commission de la concurrence pour
nous en europe
j'imagine que si elle a lancé le dossier
si elle a porté plainte c'est qu'elle a
déjà des éléments probants
ce qui ne veut pas dire que facebook
sera condamné mais la foule qui a
répondu à facebook qui a répondu via un
long communiqué et qui compte ne pas
abdiquer vous vous imaginez très bien
tout d'abord dans ce type de dossier
vous dis pas oui je suis coupable donc
c'est normal et je comprends si j'étais
à la place de mark zuckerberg
je répondrai sans aucun doute la même
chose et ensuite il est évident ce sont
des batailles judiciaires qui vont
s'ouvrir parce que les enjeux sont
importants
le rachat d'instagram c'était un
milliard de dollars le rachat de sap
dix neuf milliards de dollars 6 mai
chiffres ou mes calculs sont bons on est
sur un groupe qui pèse aux alentours de
2 800 milliards de dollars avec un enjeu
puisqu'il y a des enjeux concurrents
internationaux et sa jupe une verve
c'est donc il est évident qu'il dit je
vais me bats et puis les juges
regarderont de manière très fine
est-ce qu'il ya violation au demeurant
de manière très pratique
est ce qu'il y a et est-ce qu'il y avait
eu violation du chairman éduquer et en
actes jean-claude beaujour on sait que
facebook a créé sa propre monnaie libre
1 est ce que facebook finalement 1 en
pied de page sur les fonctions
régaliennes de l'état aujourd'hui le
groupe est il perçu comme un concurrent
politique aux etats unis
alors c'est certain que les fait qu'il y
ait aujourd'hui sur ce dossier des
attaques vie partisane aussi bien des
républicains que les démocrates que de
responsables politiques des républicains
et démocrates
le fait qu'un certain nombre de voix
s'élèvent pour pouvoir dire trop c'est
trop
il est évident qu'une risque c'est qu'il
y ait un état dans l'état et donc c'est
ce qui est anticipé et c'est ce que
veulent freiner
je peux vous dire de aux états unis ce
sont des voix qui s'élèvent et pas
simplement d'un petit état j'entends
cela en californie j'entends cela dans
des états parfois reculés on dit
attention il ne faudrait pas que
facebook le fait d'être un média un
média réseau social est important vous
souvenez des critiques de donald trump
et bien tout ceci pour dire qu'il y a un
fond de musique des partisans et qui
vient du profond d'amérique jusqu'au 6
dans l'élite dirigeants qui dit
attention il ne faut pas qu'il y ait un
état au-dessus de l'état merci jean
claude beaujour d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat et vice président du cercle de
réflexion français mairie